let's go to Kevin from San Diego Kevin
welcome what's on your mind
um first of all say sir thank you for
telling me to go to Puesto last time I
was there it was uh incredible oh my god
did you get the brisket taco
uh I did not did you say the brisket
Taco I got the I got the filet mignon
tacos I got the I got the ones with the
filet mignon and uh Lobster in them and
they were
it was like the best tacos I've ever had
that sounds criminal that sounds
criminal yeah no it's it should be
criminalized honestly but uh anyway
um okay on on that that's that's a
that's a good thing that's happened but
uh unfortunately we seem to be sliding
towards uh a bit of a bit of a fascism
um here
um I'm thinking that like do you agree
that it would be
it would be best if we had like Trump V
DeSantis get really ugly and they I
don't know if other people have talked
about this before I joined a little late
but nobody has talked about it other
than me earlier in the week I my concern
with this entire primary that is
building wherein Trump has announced
then DeSantis hasn't but there's polls
where he's already winning DeSantis that
is my priority is whatever scenario will
get these people to destroy themselves
and each other and right now the most
likely destructive path forward is you
have a very ugly primary wherein the
Trump and the DeSantis people if
DeSantis runs hate each other
so that when hopefully DeSantis wins the
primary and the reason I say that is
DeSantis won't go and run third party
but Trump might DeSantis was the primary
Trump goes and runs third party takes a
bunch of his supporters because they
hate DeSantis and just splits the vote
and a Democrat easily wins that to me
seems like the dream scenario right now
yeah I mean and I think that Trump is
probably aware that that could happen
but he's still too like arrogant and
narcissistic to not do it if he doesn't
take the primary in the first place like
he doesn't win
yeah I I don't see any way he he just
like lets it Go and doesn't
yeah he's he because he's he's just he's
just too crazy to not do that I believe
that you are exactly right which is
Trump may be so narcissistic that even
if he intellectually understands or has
people around him saying you will just
hand this to a Democrat if you run third
party I hope he does it anyway
right yeah well but we're getting ahead
of ourselves the first question is does
he win the primary we're assuming he
doesn't he still might
yeah he still might and that would be
bad I just think that like there's
enough things where the Republicans are
like kind of even it even not counting
the the current primary there's like the
the Supreme Court of morvi Harper I
don't remember exactly what which the
one that was um that that's deciding
things so that the states can make their
own things with no federal their own
election rules with no federal oversight
indeed um
which if that is decided by the court in
favor of like the what the Republicans
want
um I feel like there's a bunch of states
that are just going to be like oh yes
the Republicans won again no matter what
uh basically they're gonna make rules to
to not necessarily to
you know decide the elections against
what people actually voted but
essentially suppress enough of the vote
and uh make it to only the places that
they know are going to be voting for
Republicans are going to account
essentially indeed and uh then they'll
they'll never be won by anyone uh
anywhere close to Progressive again
that is a horrible uh uh we're if it's
horrible what you're saying but it's a
few steps ahead so let's Reserve
judgment and see what happens next if
that makes sense uh yeah well it's not
bad to think about it just to plan ahead
I I'm I'm with you I'm with you but uh I
appreciate the call
yeah it's nice talking to you all right
there is Kevin from San Diego one of our
sponsors today is blue chew a unique
online service delivering the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost and they're giving my audience
an entire month's supply for free so if
you think you could benefit from an
extra boost of confidence when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping